a delayed game is eventually good a bad
game is bad forever
you know i couldn't start a video about
game delays without referencing shigeru
miyamoto's infamous quote
but it's such a good one now we saw a
few games get delayed in 2020 but it
seems that the real impact of the
pandemic on the gaming world
is being felt in 2021 we're not even
that far into the year yet but
so many games have been delayed already
and while it's a shame
i say give devs all the time in the
world to release something that they're
proud of
here's a roundup of every game that's
been delayed so far and yes it's a shame
it sucks we'll just have to wait a
little longer to enjoy them
for more like this make sure to like
this video and subscribe arcane leon's
death loop was planned to launch in may
after already being bumped from a late
2020 window but sadly
it won't meet that date either the time
twisting action game is now coming on
september 14th and the developer said it
wanted to make sure that it can create a
fun
stylish and mind-bending player
experience
while also keeping its employees healthy
and safe
good on you arcane originally planned to
launch
in spring 2021 lego star wars the
skywalker saga has been delayed to an
unclear future date developer travellers
tales did not give an exact reason for
the delay
other than wanting to give the team more
time to deliver quote the biggest and
best ever lego game
and said it would provide new launch
information as soon as it can
sony confirmed back in february that
gran turismo 7 had been delayed into
2022.
the decision came as critical parts of
the development process were affected by
the pandemic and because of the changing
nature of the global situation
a firm date wasn't set as we get closer
to next year hopefully that will change
originally scheduled to release back in
february ubisoft delayed its extreme
sports game
riders republic just about a month prior
to launch it's now coming at an
unspecified future 2021 date and ubisoft
gave a vague statement about wanting to
deliver
the best fun-filled experience when they
announced the delay
we won't be able to get our hands is on
the lord of the rings golem until 2022
the game's precious 2021 launch got
pushed early in the year
with companies daedalic entertainment
and nikon partnering on the project
moving forward
it's still planned to release on several
different systems though including xbox
series x
ps5 nintendo switch and pc precious
return all didn't get an enormous delay
but it was delayed nonetheless
originally planned for a march launch
the ps5 exclusive roguelite third-person
shooter from house mark
is now releasing on april 30th publisher
sony said
this time would allow house mark to add
additional polish to the game
which blends its signature arcade-style
bullet-filled action with a third-person
perspective
and production values more akin to a aaa
game
kenya bridge of spirits got a delay to
early 2021
a short time after it was showcased at
the ps5's official reveal event
however that window didn't stick either
in late february it was delayed again
this time getting a firm august 24th
date for both the ps4 and ps5 versions
there is nothing to say won't be delayed
again but the new concrete day does
inspire a little more confidence that it
will actually come out this summer
originally planned for a launch this
march prince of persia the sounds of
time remake was delayed to an
unclear future back in february ubisoft
cited wanting to make a remake that
still feels fresh while staying true to
the spirit of the original version but
didn't specify how long the delay would
be
or if it's even still planned to release
in 2021
the series has largely been on icing's
assassin's creed exploded in popularity
over a decade ago
and i don't know about you but i'm dying
to see my prince again
hogwarts legacy a 19th century game
based on the harry potter series was
scheduled to release
later this year but it has been delayed
to 2022.
the delay came amid controversy
surrounding author jk rowling who was
not directly involved with the project
gotham knights a spin-off of the batman
series and a non-canonical one at that
was scheduled to arrive before the end
of 2021 before being bumped
into next year warner brothers gave a
very vague statement about wanting to
provide the best possible experience for
players but didn't really specify the
reason behind the delay beyond that
the cooperative action game is directed
by patrick redding who previously worked
on splinter cell and far cry
it's not the only dc game warner
brothers has cooking with a suicide
squad game slated for 2022.
however we wouldn't be surprised to see
that one get bumped too
a game awash with controversy and
production issues vampire the masquerade
bloodlines 2 got delayed
late last year to a 2021 date since then
publisher paradox chose to delay the
game again
this time out of 2021 completely
furthermore an
entirely new developer is working on the
project replacing the old one hard suit
labs which was subsequently
and sadly hit with layoffs dying light 2
has been delayed a few different times
and it was originally scheduled to
release about a year ago
its latest delay announced back in
january was indefinite
though it was still confirmed for 2021.
developer techland has been accused of a
toxic work environment and poor
leadership
its delays come as dead island 2 a
sequel to a game techland also created
has been in development hell for several
years and is now on its
third developer the latest 2d fighting
game from ark system works
guilty gear strive was delayed by about
two months moving from april to june 11
2021 the delay came after the game's
open beta during which the studio
solicited feedback from the community
and determined that it wanted to spend
more time polishing it before launch
this includes making improvements to
server stability as well as the online
lobbies which have sometimes been
problematic in the company's other
online fighting games
humankind the game that reportedly lets
you rewrite human history as you see fit
was delayed from april to august
as developer amplitude studios looks to
address feedback it received during a
beta period
elements the studio is looking to
improve are the pacing balancing and
diplomacy tools the user interface will
also be getting improved prior to its
new august 17th release date
back for blood a cooperative horror
shooter from turtle rock that serves as
a spiritual successor to left 4 dead was
delayed from june 22nd until
october 12th the studio didn't give any
concrete information on the reason
behind the delay
aside from wanting to improve the game
but it did say there would be an open
beta this summer for eager players
to try out a separate alpha test was
held on pc
last year first delayed in february
before being delayed again to april 1st
people can fly's outriders may have
actually benefited from the delay in
unintentional ways
a substantial demo released prior to the
game's launch giving players a chance to
try out its cooperative shooting action
and see its role-playing elements couple
that was launching day one on
game pass and it was so popular at
launch that it's had a lot of server
issues as they struggle to cope with
their numbers
wait they announced that delay already
capcom's pragmata was shown off in a
showcase for the ps5 back in 2020 but
the game has already received a delay
it isn't coming out until 2023 meaning
it's probably gonna be a long time
before we hear more about the game at
all
if you remember it gave off very strong
death stranding vibes in its previous
appearance and it's scheduled to launch
on pc ps5 and xbox series
amazon's mmo new world has been delayed
more times than we can count
seemingly one of the only games amazon
hasn't cancelled out right
new world was moved from a vague spring
2021 window
to august 31st 2021 the development team
is working to improve end game features
prior to launch
as well as add more polish to the game
overall it's just one
mmo that amazon is working on with a
lord of the rings project in the works
too
the destiny 2 expansion the witch queen
has been delayed into 2022
the scope and complexity of the
expansion and its narrative
ties to other content was one of the
reasons for the delay and the studio
wanted to avoid putting extra pressure
on the development team during the
pandemic however
content for the game including the vault
of glass raid will continue throughout
2021
i've set it up top and i'll say it again
i can't even imagine how difficult it is
to even make a game in the first place
let alone doing it in the middle of a
pandemic so it's natural that so many of
them are going to be delayed
and yes it's a shame but i hope all the
devs get all the time they need
but if you're still at a loss for some
things to play there are plenty for you
to get through
if you've got game pass we rounded up
some absolute must plays for you
so check the link in the description or
on screen right now thanks for watching
i'll catch you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you